this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for having me be seen
in 25 years it's the first time that I
give a formal talk here in front of my
my colleagues and my peers so thank you
so much for having me doing this today
so basically what I will show you is the
work that I have been done for the last
15 or 20 years actually I started this
work when I was an undergrad student and
I got a masters studying fossils from
Patagonia then I have elapsed when I
came here as a postdoc and then when it
was time for me to establish my own
research program I went back to
Argentina something that is really
important for me is collaboration and
this is part of my team I have my
colleagues from Argentina colleagues
from here least was a student here at
Cornell University now she is my
collaborator she is in Ohio my colleague
Peter will he works the infants in Penn
State and of course my group of people
that helped me when we are in the field
so this project is basically a
collaboration with several institutions
not just from Cornell and the United
States but also from Argentina so one of
the things that is important to
understand is a wire fossils important
and one of the things that we need to
concentrate is actually in the global
diversity throughout the world something
that most people don't know is that the
northern hemisphere is characterized for
being continental what means that that
means that 30% of land is in the
northern hemisphere 70% is worth
something hemisphere is characterized to
be in oceanic that is because only 6% of
land masses is what is formed the south
and hemisphere and if you consider the
part of land that is between the two
tropics the northern hemisphere is
represented one one two one
land and water and the South became is
ferries 1 to 16 so only one part of land
record 16% of water something that is
interesting about this is the fact that
of the season considered to be six
hotspot for diversity fall into the
south and hemisphere and this is
actually indicating that definitely
there's an asymmetry in the diversity of
plants and biomes in general this
latitudinal diversity it's not new is
not just in the modern times we know
that equatorial peaks in species
richness are typical not only for plants
they are also for terrestrial and marine
animals as well we know that has
increased a moderately through the
Cretaceous to the Cenozoic and that is
because we have the great appear
appearance of the vascular plants and
the unjust ferns and gymnosperm stir and
that we have buyers too late sinusoid to
Neogene vicariance events that
effectively partitioned the tropics in
centers of high diversity so we see
these Peaks since they Ordovician
they're coming up and they pick actually
with the appearance of the flowering
plants during some place here in the
Cretaceous around 140 million years ago
so what happened with the Americas this
is this talk is about patagonia so I'm
trying to go towards there so what
happened with a America in the United
States that has approximately 10 million
square kilometres it has 7 percent of
the global diversity and inches per
level and 1.4 are considered to be
endemic however if we look at Brazil
that is smaller than the United States
actually carries 98 20 percent of the
global diversity of those 66 percent an
endemic
and we know that it's a fact that around
40% of the of the Amazon basic has never
been sampled therefore we expect to have
much more in them explains there than we
know up today and what happened with
Argentina where Patagonia is located
Argentina is actually almost one-third
of the size of United States
it only has 3% of the global angiosperm
diversity and has 0.5% of endemics but
if you consider this half of the size is
approximately has the same number of
endemic stabbed the United States so we
observe this diversity asymmetry also if
we look at the Americas in general so
coming from South America it's important
for me to explain what South America is
about
more or less we have 90 thousand
vascular plants species of which in
Antarctica only has two of them but
South America and Antarctica are really
critical are extremely critical to
understand and comprehend several
factors about plants first explain the
direction and flow of the dispersion
emmigration roots of all these plants
and also animals explain the radiation
and dominance of the ancestors in the
south and hemisphere in general and also
helps to interpret the distant model of
the modern astral distribution and this
is because South America was part of
their big continent called Gondwana so
just to show you Antarctica is during
the summer it has only two percent free
of snow is the coldest windiest and
driest desert on the planet
and has only two particular plants
Columb Antos which is in the car yo
Philly AC and this champion which is a
grass Argentine
it's only a thousand miles exactly for
the Antarctic Peninsula so it's only
1600 kilometers from the Antarctic
Peninsula to the South Armagh city of
Argentina which is suya
and actually it has high diversity has
families are represented 215 we have
approximately 2,000 general and around
2009 thousand species of vascular plants
and of the ups of these 1800 are
endemics
they are only found in Argentina so what
is Patagonia Patagonia is basically the
last thousand mass of the southernmost
tip of South America is considered to be
largely inhabited and I the population
is around 4 people per kilometer square
so when you go there mostly you don't
see people around if you divide
Patagonia using the Andes you will have
two different type of environments in
general they step or the Patagonian step
which is actually flat dry plain mostly
are grasslands and if you look at the
border with Chile and the Andes what you
will see our mountain sites that are
covered by rainforests that's where we
have the numerous glaciers that extend
on both sides on the argentinian side
and the Chile Nia side so the term
Patagonia comes from actually the first
Spaniards that arrived there around 50
countries they saw this big Indians
cause they will chest and it will chase
we are very tall men up to 2 meters and
they wear look higher and taller due to
the fact that they wear
a lot of pills from one uncle's to cover
themselves and also because they use
those to cover their feet so what they
see the footstep that they Spanier so
we're the ones used by these out by
these natives so the name Patagonia
comes from there however Charles Darwin
during the trip to the beat the big old
trip with Fitzroy in commanding London
in Patagonia he was only 24 years old
and the first impression of Patagonia
was exactly this is the surface in quite
level and is composed of well-rounded
single mix with the widest earth here
and they are is character of brown wire
with grass are supported and is still
really some low thorny bushes and
actually it does exactly what Patagonia
is so we have a huge this is prepare
cabin this is one of cabinet slides and
actually it's just to show that that was
his vision is know how Patagonia is
Patagonia is extremely rich in vascular
plants and extremely endemic so we have
different type of biomes and just I will
show you only a couple of them I will
show you materials from this step and
materials that you will see close to the
valdivian forests so if you were looking
at this step extant flora oh sorry
if you were looking at the side of the
Andes what you will see are these
spectacular views these are mostly big
lakes with volcanoes covers by beautiful
forest of notify us and when - and Clube
us and also if you have the chance you
can see the perito moreno glacier which
is one of the most active pleasures in
modern times and these are some of the
endemics we have in between in the
poetry in Proteus e we have notification
looma is a mute AC which lack of bark as
many of them UTC we have the typical RL
Korea in the era of Korea s colonia and
dream is in the winter AC but if you go
to the step you have the opportunity to
see me while you are walking
penguins you can see also other kind of
wildlife such as Maureen's arms it went
out of my mind it's not important but
you can also see a different type of
bushes and brushes and some of those are
these for example area in the sea go
fillet see we have beautiful legumes are
a natural freedom we have some of the
most spectacular cut tide and we have
these are endemics we have chuckwalla
which is one of the composite ok these
are this next to it slides our photos
that I took meanwhile I was working from
the truck to one of my sides so and that
was a work of less than 1 kilometer so
he's really very rich if you are looking
down Patagonia has all kind of budgets
and brushes but the trick is to look on
the ground so we see things like a
federal holiday see we seek Tripoli a
sea like a school area Romney see in the
colleague waha this is one of the
endemics another cactus as Arella louis
AC another composite apiaceae
another ones like in natera
a bunch of legumes and several monocots
so this is charge from the work from the
truck to one of my sites so they the
flora is incredible and then also me
what you are collecting you are really
lucky on see a lot of wildlife such as
condors when I chose penguins
Andrea's these are flightless birds so
how did Patagonia reach the high
diversity the present flora to answer
that question definitely we need to look
at the fossil record fossils are
extremely important no chance to check
for endemics or no chance to explain
modern distribution but they actually
provide additional information to assess
quality and evolutionary change through
time they also provide character
evidence that effect our phylogenetic
conclusion so one of the things that we
do is include all these fossils within
the phylogenetic analysis that helps us
to understand more than relationship not
just past relationships fossils also
help to estimate the minimal
ages of certain clays that they are
prisoner and those definitely are the
best source for calibration for
molecular dating finally they also help
to understand the evidence of past
distribution therefore they can aid us
to understand biogeographic histories
not only from the past but also from the
present so we have several papers in
which we've been utilizing the [ __ ]
record to answer different questions for
example we provide lists of Monaco's
that are suitable for molecular dating
analysis we also study the Cenozoic
biogeographical evolution of goodI
plants we are able to understand
phylogenetic biome conservatism if we
look at the fossil record comparing them
with extra material and fine
we are able to do some testing to impact
of how we do calibration treatments
using fossils so fossils really are key
for any kind of study that you want to
do so the research questions these are
the big research questions that we have
in in my group are basically based on
Patagonia and one of the questions we
thought is was Patagonia a refuge from
the M of Cretaceous maxes station and I
will we go to that in a little bit if
you remember during the KPG boundary was
a mass extinction many vertebrates group
disappear many plants disappear however
the event is completely different in the
northern hemisphere than the south
hemisphere and why is that because again
we have bad differences in the top the
northern hemisphere being continental
that south and chemists are being
oceanic what are the composition
diversity and biogeography affinities of
early Paleocene Eocene flora and why is
this important because if we have mass
extinction at the end of the Cretaceous
we need to have something at the
beginning of the apology so we are
interested in Damian Flores which is the
South the most basal part of the
pollutant and one of the things that we
are very lucky is because we shop the
only Danian in the south and chemists
are represented in Patagonia so are
these flora contain lineages that now
survive South America Asia Africa as
well as Australasia do they document the
early phases of South America and
isolation by showing a loss of congo
anna taxa and increasing the new word
taxa our evolutionary processes
processes register in the fossil record
so this is something that we attempt to
answer not today will be impossible for
me to answer all those questions but we
are working towards answered them
so the journey has stars much before we
get today today film so first we start
collecting information and checking
geological maps here in my library then
if we are lucky enough that United
doesn't cancel my fly from Ithaca I'm
able to arrive to New York I'm from
there I fly all the way to Buenos Aires
from when aside as I fly again to a
small town called parallel where my
colleagues from the Museo paleontology
Coheed of Aurelio or myth our house and
that's where I spend most of my time
when I go to Argentina before leaving to
the film if you go to Toledo you have
the chance to stop in the Touring Club
this is the Touring Club and around 99
1900 species today and there is where
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid stay
you can stay in the room it charge you a
little extra money
you can sit also at the table where
George Simpson write some of his books
he was a visitor there for several years
in the 30s and finally you can also sat
at a table where excites up untwine
exonic super ii wrote part of the little
prince book so you can do all those
things when you go to Train L class work
in the collections so what do we do we
work at the collections first we check
numbers we also get ready to go to the
field so we carry everything we carry
from the water food before leaving from
the film we take pictures of course and
we drive and drive sometimes we get into
situations where is dubious if you can
pass with the truck or no we were able
to after three days if the tracks breaks
are there's no the shop you need to come
up to the occasion and everybody works
to try to fix the truck
lucky enough you come maybe arrive on
time to set your tent which it will be
your house for the next 15 days and then
if the wind doesn't blow does the tent
where you will have hopefully some
dinners and lunches
maybe now we never go out of the pill
without having a dinosaur detector I
suppose such as said by the people in
Jurassic Park and actually we keep an
eye open if we see bones we were very
lucky to find not too long ago bones of
the loved one of the largest dinosaurs
in in Patagonia and on the earth so
concentration we are working in many
different Paolo Flores I will just
mention three of them today because
these are the most spectacular ones I
will be talking about La Colonia
formation which is that one that is in
the KPG boundary is the most companion
to Maastricht and in h de salamanca
formation which is dannion that puts us
in the early Paleocene around 65 million
years ago and then the tufa leta Laguna
del junco which is basically a tough
they were just stuff is just ashes and
ashes and ashes it the two Politis
Laguna alum Co is compared today what
you have in Yellowstone is considered to
be one of the largest mega calderas for
theyíre seeing worldwide and that I the
age of that to Paula died is I present
which is an early policy so basically
what we are looking is from La Colonia
to the Salamanca to the to Politis
Laguna Lucca and here is where you will
have the KPG boundary this is just I
don't want to over menu with geology but
this is just to show you how the south
and chemistry look in polar view during
a specific time so these seas around
amassed ricktum and as you can see we
have it still little con wanna start to
break at around the track
but major movements started from the
Triassic all the way to modern times so
here is the reconstruction for the
maastricht Ian this is a brief
reconstruction for the dannion one for
the using which is depression and
finally disease today is the
reconstruction one of the things that I
want to point it out here is about this
point this point and this points we
didn't have the circumpolar current
so the temperature at that point was is
still high so when we hear their ears in
what we are hearing is the maximum
thermal during the tertiary and that is
important because is when we start to
change different type of taxa and we
will see that in a minute once we are in
the field we continue driving we drop
the cars there and then we walk to the
sediments where we will be collecting
it's not easy it's not vacation time
like most people think we carry heavy
machinery to break the rocks in this
case you can see here we have a rotary
so once we have what is called a quarry
which is the place where we work at
where fossils we do a lot of on hand
activities chests are using the pick and
shovels and cleaning the quarry we
obtain rocks and we pick the rocks we
divide the rocks we clean the fossils we
select the fossils in the field we pack
them and finally we live a clean quarry
for the following day having a clean
quarry helps you to do paleoecological
studies we take every single fossil that
every single fossil that we excavate is
recorded that allow us to do fish anomic
analysis which basically allow us to
calculate maximum temperatures and also
based on those characters we also are
able to produce
small temperature and a ring so these
studies are really important so what are
the Middle's that we use obviously on
the fossils are collected we take it to
their collections and they are the
Apostles are prepared we use standard
methods depends on the fossils we do it
by hand sometimes we have a little tools
that help us to do that you will see
later on sometimes we are able to obtain
pollen grains in situ so that those are
a study with TEM and SEM as well and we
are try to include all our photos within
a phylogenetic context so basically what
we do is at oral evidence approach for
this we use matrices that have already
provided I've had already published if
they are not we produce our own a
morphological matrices we combine those
with molecular data that we obtain from
gene Bank and other sources and
sometimes you will find that we need
some key taxa that needs to be explored
for the relationship we even do our own
instruction of DNA and these are just
some of the things that we use we use
maximum persimmony and we use use a
maximum likelihood on all our projects
sometimes fossils can not be included
and we don't so the methodology that we
use is basically to go to our buyer
sheet compare what do we have there and
try to figure it out where we can place
these fossils in what families so we do
a lot of modern and modern taxonomy or
systematics of these groups so now
colonial formation our crops in the
Samoa
massive is considered to be upper
cretaceous and one of the things that is
important is for all the deformations
that we present today we have a very
good detriment eh so the age in this
case is 65 to 83 if based on many
current
geographic markers so we know that the
formation is 72 million years old it has
three different fascias which means
three different type of environments
where the forces were a deposit and what
is important here is that all our
fossils come from the lower and middle
phases which are represented by coastal
freshwater lakes or fresh water lagoons
and I will not show you all the fossils
today but I want to make sure that is
one the fossils that we have found there
are represented by the family salvini AC
which is a equity fern Dixon II AC
source of ferns
we have several conifers but the most
prominent one are from the familiar
Akari I see we have the first and oldest
record of Nagumo Lacy which is an
aquatic plant we have pumps the family
Eric AC and we have T faci also is
considered to be an offshore kind of
plant
we have several dicots and monocots
leave from Morpho types we are working
on that but also we have an extremely
rich Paulino flora which is basically
pollen grains and spores so I will show
you just a couple of examples and I'm
very proud of their solar because this
is the oldest record worldwide of a cold
plant that means we have the sporophyte
and we have these four Oh cups and those
inside the sporocarp sir this is the
plant this is one of the poorer cups we
were able to pull out the Mayla spores
and each megaspore has stick to it the
microspores and those micro spores are
represented by these little things here
and this is a specific type of extension
of the wall called a clock idea
the glochidia are fundamental for the
micro sport to reach the floaters of the
megaspores and then copulate
marci liaison is also an aquatic firm
they are it's a very small family with
three genera and we have here this is
represented a very close to the genus
Martin Maher cilia which has four
leaflets we have the four leaflets here
and in this case we also find the
sporocarp and regnal idiom which is only
is endemic of a small area in Brazil
away and Argentina has a rich fossil
record in the northern hemisphere not in
the South ek mister however we found
that in log whoops we founded in La
Colonia with the two leaflets and this
is flora carbs yield the mega spores
which has called more last fora when you
find it that is not associated and
chrisphillip or it is which are these
ones here so these are the oldest
records for the family Marci Lee I see
worldwide the Salamanca formation
belongs to a completely different
formation and basin is the son jorge
basin we know that is Dan Ian is really
well established the age is the only
South and hemisphere Danian sediments is
represented by Australian deposits and
one of the things that we know is that
has one of the most fantastic
invertebrate flora M in vertebrae
furnace and among them is one of the
breaches for insects it also has a rich
Bellino flora but the mega flora is
almost unknown and that is because we
have a lot of and just firm or four
times does are the ones that we don't
know where to put them
the formation was discovered many many
years ago but it still we started
something around it 2007
and that's where we go they always
record for the re Casey represented by
the ethylene II subscribe
these are their seats the Charlotte I'm
sorry those are actually the fruits you
can see here they have the three bulbs
they have only two pores and these are
the seeds we extend distribution of the
a tahini is this area northern part of
Argentina and again we did a
phylogenetic analysis and is place
within this trade of the ethylene e we
also this is work with my with Nathan my
actual my postdoc at this time so here
we have the oldest record from Nasik
were y as well
it's a flower and is characterized abide
as being pentamerous they have a very
distinctive type of colleagues they have
the clock cookie laid a margin eight
petals petals and the family is today
work well distributed but the fossil
record is not very abundant again we
included a phylogenetic context and it
fits within the CC points which are
found today in there in the Americas we
have also found Koonin EAC which is a
typical South and Hemisphere family in
Argentina we have only four genera clock
rubia okra Elliman Anya and when Manya
and we have this one this flower that
but is the number of parts the suppose
are three you have a very distinctive
type of venation but the most important
thing are the pillows which are here and
this is characteristic of one of the
groups between their fight within the
family and each day is key CAC and we
found the pollen grains within the
anthers again we included a phylogenetic
and his place as the sister of the crank
group excuse Oh Mary and this is
important because later on I will show
you another fossil that belongs to the
same group another Coonan yes see this
is Kenyatta be careful akka and again we
found the distinctive [ __ ] on EAC
morphology we found the pollen grains in
situ here and these are the pollen
grains of ammonia and Colombia which are
two of the general diet grows in
Argentina today and again it was
included in a phylogenetic context and
this one feeds as the core in the base
of the core of the whole punani AC what
are the two philetus laguna alum code
does considered to be one of the largest
volcanic rock lastic complex worldwide
the photo comes from two facials mats
and these are representing caldera like
deposits exactly the same as if today
Yellowstone will erupt we know exactly
the age fifty two million years ago and
this is actually one of the highest
value by orders worldwide and is highest
is the richest years in Flores were why
even comparing with United States we
have found Toledo fight gymnosperms and
several unjust firms and these are some
of the gymnosperms as retro feelin in
the polar cap AC Papua cedrus a Gatti's
in the Arabic reac
a daddy's is totally extent in Argentina
is only found in certain areas of
Australasia we shops dingo it is and
this is the cuticle as you can see here
this is the last record of dingo areas
worldwide and this is the one that gave
origin to the Gingles as we know today
and then we have our Stroh Samia
which is in the seeker AAC among those
we found the oldest record of eucalyptus
and
of the things that is important is we
have a whole plant there we have the
Leafs with a typical type of by nation
we have deep roots there are the
capsules that have the bulbs and we have
flowers and within the flowers we were
able to obtain pollen grains and these
pulling grains are what if you find an
isolated as military Severus eucalyptus
and this is the type that is considered
to be the precursor of the genus
eucalyptus or eucalyptus so again we are
included in a phylogenetic context this
is isolated multi seed ideas and as we
can see the Patagonian fossils are
placed within the genus eucalyptus this
is the other kunin yes see that we found
this is remember this is tertiary these
belongs again to the super our to the
tribe is key so Mary
these are the fruits we have other
colony acid that we are being a study at
this point but as you can see this is
modern way money these are characterized
by having these a capsules that open
with two bulbs and they have the
remnants of their styles and you can see
this one is one of those with this
typical opening with the Stars and we
have another one here these are totally
two different types of fossils these at
the typical pinnacle and this is a
typical regime so we know the colony was
much more diverse that when we have
today in living we have also fossils of
the jigglin day see these are correct
these are fruits they are not less and
these allow us to actually we did a CT
scan to actually observe that the
embryos and the cotyledons
are separated in four and they are
together dusky to determine if these
belong to two gland AC or not again we
included in a phylogenetic context and
it fits within the angle gar
yo D and angle gallery are represented
today in the northern part of South
America and Central America there's node
in Argentina and of course we have
stolen a seed that was so really
important because Solanaceae are mostly
herbaceous thing they are very important
a group for crops but we found this
beautiful preserve very similar to the
modern some of the border general and in
this case very similar to the fruits
that are produced by Sally's the family
is today were Y distributed we know that
the origin of the family is the this
South America and one of the things is
that we were able to infer the provide
that we are distributed they were
dispersed by the rivers because these
have the syndrome of the floating calyx
again we place it I don't expect for you
to read this but we place it here within
the corpus Alice so we have actually
northern connections or some connections
fountain connections so in the northern
connection this is they actually this is
they must strict in the Scout you will
see it
we have regnal idiom we have the Marcy
Lea area Sola we have grains of disease
actually organized a poly nightís which
is a deficit we have array see this is
the oldest record DC said the genius
pandan itis which is an array see this
is praveen actually we find also the
mega fossils
those are aquatic plants and of course
we have not a fat adidas we have certain
connection is indicated also by these
fern this is the genus todya we have
agate is in their locker a see we have
the jigglin they see we have gymnast oma
which is Kathryn acid today this is
totally extinct in Argentina and
grows in certain parts of Australasia we
have the eucalyptus and we have several
Kanye Seng
so based on this information what we can
say actually is that we can observe
certain evolutionary processes such as
extinction we don't have a godís or
eucalyptus or Kasserine AC anymore in
South America however they are all of
those are represented by the oldest
records in the Eocene of Argentina we
have also an expansion we have this
Alvin Ailey's those are the aquatic
ferns we have they are a sea we have not
Apogee kundunese he amputee sea which
have expanded based on the fossil record
to other areas of South America and the
south and hemisphere we have definitive
retraction of several taxes such as Rek
see remember if we have here the palms
and now they are restricted to this area
they are really retracted based on
paleontology we can say the same about
the family rubiaceae and finally there
are several things that are explaining
disjunction models such as the familiar
winter a/c and iraq reac which have
discharge we have some of those in the
northern part of Argentina some in the
south so in summary I want to make sure
that you know that actually fossils are
really critical and they provide an
unprecedent worth of information not
only on Cretaceous and tertiary Flores
but also if we compare them with ekstam
Flores to understand certain things they
provide knowledge on past south and
distribution which is critical for
understanding modern global distribution
if you remember the first slide I said
that was an estimate a symmetry in the
latitudinal gradients of diversity so
this is proving that that is actually
occurring
these Polly Flores are certain relevant
for explaining modern high diversity
centers and evolutionary processes are
really
in the Palio floristic record of
Patagonia and for all of you we actually
we need to celebrate the past to awaken
their future and that is because we
actually genomic information is
extremely important molecular data is
critical but also we have the other
component so we have if we don't study
the taxonomy past distribution modern
distribution we are missing a lot of
critical information that helped us to
understand actually the value of that
genomic and molecular data with that I
say thank you this has been funded by
several agencies NSF may full Brian
Coney said nothing of this can be done
without the staff of the museum people
here Cornell has a fantastic herbarium
which I use quite frequently we cannot
do this work if we didn't have access to
all of our our sites and to my to
becomes question yes it's a it's a task
so first of all we really clean them so
that in in the field we we get the big
rocks and we treat them there so we
don't carry all that the way to the to
the field these collections are
approximately Laguna del junco has more
than a thousand specimens total so what
the dual later is when we get into their
lab we trim them again and we have a
special tools to treat them demean
two-dimensionally and then if possible
we wash them with water and after that
we just put it on their cameras and take
the pictures
oh he buries a virus we have things that
are mystic and we have things that are
distinct yeah oh okay yeah yeah I got I
go all the way down and then I go here
and you know no is there strong
directionality as to the north-south
direction we do okay we do actually and
of course I don't have the time to
explain all these so what's happening is
based on the position of Patagonia
during this time he was still connected
to Antarctica so what we are doing is
actually we are missing all the record
for Antarctica now the peninsula and
several of the islands that are close to
the Antarctic Peninsula during the
summer you can go and collect so that's
the next step there are very few works
that have been done there it started in
the 1900 with the treats of northern
whole with the boat called the
Antarctica he was his his father was a
geology so early on in his life although
he was a person that was interested in
hunting whales and that's why they did
the trip with Antarctica
they were interested he was interested
in collecting rocks so he collected
actually a bunch of fossils that are
considered now today they also type for
the oldest records for not the faggus
those who are a study in sweden by north
by Doosan which is a very famous
paleobotanist
so there are material there and we are
trying to to get to it so if everything
goes okay maybe in a couple of years I
would be going there and collect and
those we the nice thing about these is
that they will have the whole sequence
from the Maastricht and all the way
actually to the myosin there are very
interesting things happening here and we
have myosin Florez to pick Flora's in
Tierra del Fuego and those are critical
because does when almost all the species
of North follows are recorded so the
knot of our screw goes this way but we
actually did all this record is falling
grains from the maastricht end of
Antarctica so when do you start to see
the current it does it just depends so
then the last big thing that appear
where the Andes
that they started to elevate during the
Maya scene and at the end is when we
start to see already the artists area
already the diagonal already established
so it's still there biggest changes are
mostly observed after the PTM there
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum thus
when the geological aspects does when
the current the Antarctic currents start
to be more prominent so is when during
the Oligocene you start to observe the
curve already the temperatures start to
go down and at the beginning of the olio
scene is when you start to see the
elation in antarctica so all those
things are affecting what you are
getting into the into Patagonia and this
is only this is based not only in the
data I presented today of course there
are many many examples so
with for example with the north of ours
we start to observe when notify us
appears also missiles and races start to
appear and we know that miss addendum is
actually simpler ik with not follows he
grows all your not foul so we start to
observe as well those kind of events all
the major clades we this this is
actually kind of noon and one of the
things is something hemisphere is
considered to be extremely under sample
and there are many biases why this is
occurring first again is oceanic is now
considered to be continental so there's
no too many long where you can go and
look for fossils
then there's for example you have africa
africa is almost doesn't have almost any
sedimentary rocks which is where you
find the fossils and then until not too
many years ago i nobody was interested
in what was happening in South and
hemisphere because you could explain
everything studying things in the
northern hemisphere actually the
original original Polly botanist we are
from the northern hemisphere so the way
that these Flores were collected until
their fifties was based on all companies
so they send the geologists to respect
for oil they collect some fossils they
bring them to United States and they
study them so until the 50 that was the
methodology after the 50s 1950s the
thing is start to change and more people
was more involved in other aspects of
Palio botany not just you know
indicators of oil so we are trying to
collect we expect that we will find
actually more interesting things for
example we have the genus value Isola
and poly Isola has actually three mega
sports that we call
see that that are viable and without any
doubt he belongs to salvini Elias it
belongs he said it's an aquatic firm so
there are all those things that we still
need to experiment with thank you so
much this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu